[Music]
hello and welcome to another edition of
I'd like to know my name is C Murray and
it is my privilege and pleasure to to
welcome you and to thank you for joining
us today I'm in the company of two
distinguished men of God Pastor David
Salazar you to my left and Pastor Steven
bour to my right and together we form
the the dare I say triumvirate that is
here to answer your questions and we
have a good time in doing so we want you
to par participate and we ask you to
write us to email us just get word to us
anywh you can you can use snail Mill you
can use it electronic mail you can use
social media get the questions in and
write them to TV at
susum tv.org that's TVM tv.org and we
will get to your questions with answers
as soon as we can from the word of God
we make that promise to you each and
every time we go into the word of God
and we answer your questions we
guarantee you that the answers will come
from the word of God and um if there's
an answer will be found we will try as
best we can to find it find it Pastor if
David if you would uh launch out in
prayer then we can get started and
Pastor B I will ask you to read uh the
first question question which comes to
us from Switzerland so we are uh being
watched and uh uh prayed for I guess and
and blessed in uh in Europe so thank you
much let's pray Heavenly Father we come
humbly before you and your throne of
grace to ask for the dwelling of the
holy spirit in our minds for you to send
uh your spirit to teach us to lead us
into all truth and to present the
answers to the questions that our
friends have sent not from our own
understanding or own thinking but it
really may be from you and through your
word help us to uh give Clarity to the
answers so that people may be drawn
closer to you and I pray that you will
once again lead us today as we approach
these important questions we pray in
Jesus name amen amen and amen Pastor B
Christian is writing from Switzerland
what does he have to
say okay good day to you all first I
want to acknowledge my deep
appreciation uh for the expositions of
the Bible on this program I do not mean
to underrate anyone else but in time
past it has helped me tremendously
uh the question is as follows having
been baptized in the waters years ago
and not having LED almost none or so to
Christ in other words he hasn't LED
anyone to Christ as far as he knows I
wonder about my
christlikeness and so if I do not uh
supernaturally witness Jesus then do I
not do the bidding of the en Enemy by
default in other words if I'm not
winning Souls am I not doing the work of
the Enemy by default then I'm very preup
preoccupied as to how I should do the
will of God to not find myself on Shaky
Ground what then is the me mental
mechanism that I should undertake that
leads me to action uh and then in
parenthesis Ephesians
2:10 so basically uh he feels deficient
because he has not uh won anyone to
Christ at least as he
surmises uh so what counsel can we give
uh to this person uh what encouragement
can we
give well you know I think that if first
of all I want to I think is important to
recognize his desire to want to show
Christ want to follow that call that God
has given to every single one of his
disciples that we are to go and make
other disciples so it's I feel that's a
good thing to start you know the fact
that he wants to have a Christlike
experience and he's feeling that he's
not performing to that wonderful calling
um now with that said it is important to
remember that speaking of Christ it may
seem hard um to many people if you're
introvert if you are not uh you know
easy to to speak with someone else it
might be difficult but honestly speaking
of Jesus is actually the easy part if
you will I think that the harder part is
always living as Christ showing Christ
in every single thing you do and he he
know he mentions uh in his question
Ephesians 2:10 and I want to read that
verse uh to to sort of give us the
experience of what I Believe Christian
wants to have and I think it's a good
thing it says there for we are his
workmen ship created in Christ in in
Christ Jesus and to Good Works which God
had before ordained that we should walk
in them so yes God has given us
this this path he has made this election
for us that we can per perform these
good works for his glory but this living
in the good works or doing the work of
Christ it's a experience that is a daily
and experien
experimental choice of living or or
acting upon every single day so it
doesn't mean that you have to preach
about Christ but it means your actual
daily experience of life whether you're
a carpenter whether you are a plumber
whether you are electrician it doesn't
matter what you are you have to remember
that Christ wants to be shown through
every action that you do so if he's in a
situation where his work may think I'm
just uh I don't know just do the
cleaning of of the of the office or I do
just the uh I don't know the putting up
uh uh painting or whatever might be he
doing you know he has to remember that
it's actually in that experience where
he can show Christ if you do the work as
best as you can and glorify God in every
single aspect that's a way you start
already representing Jesus and maybe
pointing in your experience in your
actual work the
the way of Christ in your life to others
I tell this I say this because of an
experience that I had I remember that
with a few people you know that I work
with or had I had a little company of
building and remodeling and many times
after we would do the work some of these
or or our our um customers would
actually get me to do the work and they
would be living far away or they may not
be in in in their in their dwelling
and they would not we would not see each
other for many weeks until we finished
the work and they will come and see and
and see that the work was done as best
or better than they expected they will
be impressed and they will ask questions
like how is it that you do this kind of
work you know so well I mean you guys do
such an amazing work and I had the
opportunity to then explain to them well
we don't do it for you we do it for the
honor of Glory of God and this is why we
don't cut Corners we don't do you know
try to put cheap material whatever we do
very ethically very very clearly
transparent and so it's in these ways
where you can actually present Christ
and not necessarily just in the aspect
of preaching which he might not have the
skill you know the talent for that so I
don't know if that no I I I like that
quite a bit um I've got a couple things
that come to my mind he may not be a
tool of the enemy but he may be Leo Dean
and if he is indeed Leo toan he's got a
lot of company there are a lot of people
who are sort of Benchwarmers who come to
church every week but for one reason or
another do not go out and share their
gospel a couple things I want to say um
Ellen White Acts of Apostles page 600
Christ has given to every church member
a sacred charge every member should be a
channel through which God can
communicate to the world the treasures
of his
grace Ephesians 2:10 was always one of
my favorite texts because it's it's just
a couple texts behind Ephesians 28 which
tells us we are saved by grace through
faith but then it says but we are
created for work right God wants us to
work it is the purpose of God that the
Plan of Salvation shall not be wrought
out independent of human
instrumentalities one of the things I
think uh Christian ought to do is pray
for God to show him where he can be of
service to his kingdom you would be
surprised of the number of things that
would leave someone to the Lord I give
you this quick story when I was at 3:00
ABN uh a woman heard me on the radio she
heard me
laughing and she said in her mind as she
was in a nursing home anybody that
laughs like that has to know the Lord
true story so she called one of the
nurses she said would you call that
station find out who that guy is and
tell him I would like to see him and it
just so happened that that nurse knew my
wife Irma so she called Irma Irma told
me there's a lady in the nursing home
who heard you laugh and wants to meet
you so I took Irma with me I thought
we'd be there 5 minutes we were there 3
hours she gave her heart to the Lord we
baptized her she was crippled and could
not walk and so I had in my van I built
a a a a a a ramp so that we could wheel
her wheelchair up and I went up and
picked her up every morning and took her
to church until she died about two years
later but it began with a laugh so you
never know what the Lord can use right
if you dedicate yourself to him he will
show you what you can do for him if you
ask in sincerity you don't have to be a
couch potato you don't have to be a a
benchwarmer you can get in the game and
God will give you success for your
labors if you really want to have it
amen you know one other thing which I
think is extremely
important is that we have the tendency
to focus on that which has
value you know we don't buy junk well
some people buy junk but generally we
don't focus on buying junk as such right
um if we
realized the value of one Soul yeah if
we saw Souls as Jesus sees them we would
be much more focused on winning Souls
investing our resources investing our
time investing our strength investing
everything for the Salvation of souls uh
I have here the some Choice statements
from this Spirit of prophecy about the
value of souls how much was one Soul
Worth to
Christ he was focused he had unifocus
yeah on
souls and how much was he willing to pay
for the
souls his life his life right I mean 30
plus years here on this Earth yeah you
know for if necessary only one soul I
want to read just a few of the
statements here here the wealth of
Earth dwindles into
insignificance when compared with the
worth of a single soul for whom our Lord
and Master died yeah he who weighs the
hills in scales and the mountains in a
balance regards a human soul as of
infinite
value here's another one the soul is of
infinite value it's worth can be
estimated only by the price paid to
Ransom it yeah Calvary Calvary Calvary
will explain the true value of the Soul
uh that's gospel workers 93 uh six
testimonies 21 and 22 one soul is of
more value to Heaven than a whole world
of property houses lands money for the
conversion of one Soul we should act are
resources to the utmost amen amen
Ministry of healing 135 if but one Soul
would have accepted the gospel of his
grace Christ would to save that one have
chosen his life of toil and humiliation
and his death of Shame you
know we pass by people every day do we
really see the value in them that Jesus
saw in them well said if we can never
work for Souls unless we realize what
their value is no she says that the
value of a soul is
infinite so how do you buy something of
infinite value only by paying an
infinite price and so and so don't Focus
I get the impression in this question
that he's saying well you know I really
need to witness you know because someday
the Lord is going to hold me accountable
that's that's not the real reason why we
should witness we should witness because
we want to see the salvation of Souls
and the interesting thing is the loss of
one Soul yes is something that can never
be replaced nobody can
replace a person who is lost and by the
way that's the reason why Secrets
unsealed exists you know to save souls
to strengthen the souls in the church
and to bring Souls into the fold so that
uh you know they can be saved in Christ
Kingdom amen amen amen the last thing he
asked you know and I think is important
um to answer his one of the part of the
question is like what is the mental
mechanism that he needs to have you know
Philippians 2:5 says let you know this
mind being you which was in Christ Jesus
and and it's kind of the thing where it
speaks of how
Christ became a servant and he came to
serve us to minister to to us I think
that as you mentioned Pastor you know B
the the blessing or the value of a soul
is so important that if we put that mind
set in our hearts in our minds we took
take the mind of Christ where we are
interested or invest in saving them in
serving and minister to them you will
find ways to reach them and get the Lord
will reveal to you how you can reach
them using the talents that you have and
the Lord will add to those talents even
more
because you are in for the right reason
you start loving Souls as Christ loved
them and you have the same mind and you
realize I'm going to serve them it's GNA
really make the difference and it's not
about you know how many you have put
them into baptism you know it's not a
number it's going to be just being that
channel of love and service to others
that Christ wants us to have so yes yeah
and it's not his job to convert them
anyway you just reach out and do the
work of the Lord yes and the Lord will
work through you I wanted to answer that
last question also just one line long
has God waited for the spirit of service
to take possession of the whole church
so that everyone shall be working for
him according to his ability ask God to
show you what your ability is you have
one he has blessed you with the talent
you just need to tap into it surrender
to the Lord and then watch the Lord work
for you and through you uh to lead men
and women to Christ you know and and CA
just uh just to close this question um
individuals who would not witness when
they come to know Jesus they become bold
you have for example the Samaritan woman
MH I mean she went at noon to take out
water right she was embarrassed to be
around people around the people of her
City but when she had an encounter with
Jesus and came to know him yes she
became bold so maybe the problem is that
we don't have a relationship with Christ
yes yeah and when she did she went back
to her town and she went from house to
house this is my own inspiration by the
way anyway she lets the whole town know
yes that she has met the Savior and and
she she she doesn't keep it to herself
she says come on I'll show you him yes
and the whole town later comes to see
Jesus so uh God can make us bold when
we've been couch po to use ca's term
yes amen and amen pray and be Earnest
with yourself and with God and ask him
to show you amen you may have hidden
talents that you know not of because you
haven't requested sometimes you have not
because you ask not if you ask in
sincerity then you put God on the hook
to give you a place to serve him in his
cause and I guarantee you that is a
prayer that he will not turn a DE to
amen all righty uh Pastor David let's
read this last question see if we can
sneak it in before our time right Eugene
writes this question from Bahamas what a
blessing to have someone there from
Bahamas to reach out to us the question
is an interesting one and I'm sure that
uh we'll have fun trying to answer this
question um what was Lucifer the
covering cherub and Michael the
Archangel the two angels of the Arc of
the Covenant in the Heavenly
Sanctuary so you know they're using I'm
assuming uh what Eugene thinks is that
the Arc of the Covenant that we saw the
model that was you know Dawn by by Moses
in in The Exodus um he had two uh Kims
and so he's thinking is Lucifer and
Michael the Archangel those two angels
in the Throne of God I'll take the easy
one because mine is easy Ezekiel 28:1
14-16 talks about the art the chff that
cover it yeah
yeah I had a teacher in the Seminary
maybe you knew him carsten Johnson I
knew who he was but I did not have him
we carry some of his books yeah you know
very complicated style writing style I
think he was from Sweden and uh you know
he uh taught a class where he shared
that he believed that Lucifer was on one
side of the Ark and Christ on of course
on the right side because he's at the
right hand of God MH and uh and that the
jealousy began because the father
favored uh Christ over
Lucifer and uh he even believed and he
was teaching at the Andrew University
Theological Seminary he even believed
that um Christ had
condescended to the position of an Angel
when the Angels were created because he
was the commander of the Heavenly
hosts um you know and and as I've
studied that uh there seems to be a lot
of uh a lot of light uh when you really
put all the pieces together that Lucifer
was a covering cherub and of course you
mentioned Ezekiel tells us maybe we can
read those verses I think that'd be
important being that uh we need to
address the question with the Bible uh
so do you have that uh David Ezekiel you
said I think it's
28 begin at verse begin at ver yeah okay
it says here
son of men take up a lamentation upon
the king of Ty and say unto him thus
said the Lord God thou seest up the sun
full of wisdom and perfect in
Beauty thou H has been in Eden the
Garden of God every precious stone was
th covering the Sardis the topas the
Diamond the verel the onx the Jasper the
safire the m merald and the cavern
knuckle and gold the workmanship of of
thy tabrets and of thy pipes was
prepared in thee in the day that thou
has created Thou Art the anointed cherub
that cover and I have set thee so th was
upon the holy mountain of God thou has
walked up and down in the midst of the
stones of fire that was perfect in thy
ways from the day that thou was created
till iniquity was found in thee by the
multitude of the mer of thy merchandise
they have filled the midst of thee with
violence and thou has sinned therefore I
will cast thee as profane out of the
Mountain of God and I will destroy thee
o covering chero from the midst of the
stones of fire so you know that's the
the verses that explain there show that
yes Lucifer was the covering cherub yeah
and you know the the text that that is
in the background of this one from
Ezekiel is uh in Exodus chapter 25 and
verse 20 mhm where uh it talks about the
Ark of the Covenant on
Earth which was really a shadow of the
Heavenly one right according to Hebrews
chapter 8: 1 and 2 it says here in
Exodus
25:20 and the
cherubim shall stretch out their wings
above covering The Mercy Seat there's
the key word cover that is used in
Ezekiel 28 covering the mercy seat with
their wings and they shall face one one
another the faces of cherubim shall be
toward The Mercy Seat uh so uh it talks
about cherubs and it talks about them
covering and there's two of them yeah
and we know that one of them undoubtedly
was Michael Christ so it's not beyond
the realm of possibility that the other
one was actually Lucifer and that's he
rebelled in the very presence of God I
mean it's it says that he's a cover was
a covering cherub so there is a very
likely
like you said conclusion that is the
case if you bring the text together you
know where they were you know the
position that they were in you know what
they covered you know that they were
facing one another so it it is it is so
intriguing that sin would begin at that
place right there in the presence of God
uh uh Lucifer and it Bears noting we
want to make this very very clear that
even though Christ was one of the
covering cherubs uh he was fully God oh
yes and that what awakened the jealousy
of Lucifer he says why does a father
favor him well because Jesus is 100% God
like the father right uh but Lucifer
tried to deceive the Angels into
thinking that Jesus was on a level of
equality with him and the father played
favorit so we need to make it very clear
that Christ is not just a common Angel
Michael the Archangel is a name that is
given to Christ and Jesus like the
father is 100% God we need to make that
absolutely clear absolutely the
president of the United States is
commander and chief of the army he's not
a soldier right I don't know if any well
Dwight eisenh was a soldier he's not
even a general right except for
Eisenhower except for Eisenhower but but
but he's he's still commanderin-chief of
the army of of the whole military right
so um that gives us a bit of a
correlation there he is the Lord but he
is commander-in-chief of of all the
angels of all of heaven so well done
well done very good well we are at the
end of another they go so very very fast
because there is so much to say once you
open the word of God we trust this has a
blessing has been a blessing to you it
certainly has been a blessing to us keep
writing your questions let us know if
you can and if you will where you're
writing from it helps us to know uh
where we're reaching and what our
footprint is well our time has fast
slipped into eternity allow me in
closing to with you both Grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
we'll see you again soon bye-bye and God
bless shalom
[Music]